okay all right i'm ready for the lesson
oh an hour's too quiet okay i'm gonna
have to turn it up do you want to start
with just a warm up
cause i was giving this position to my
chat
um and this should really just be a
one-minute exercise
okay all right i hope i can solve it in
one minute so
i think what i'll do because this this
position it's
not yet a tactical moment but okay
the first question is what would you
play here like if you had
even treat this as a blitzky and you
have like 15 to 20 seconds to make a
move
what would be the natural move that you
play here i would play
95 because normally if they take we want
to attack on h7 and i already i haven't
castled yet so taking here for
black shouldn't be good awesome okay so
this is kind of the first thing to
understand is you don't want to castle
because there's potential for the h file
to open
uh if black trades on g3 so
knight e5 good move and now let's
imagine like takes g3
okay uh how would you continue h takes
okay so here's where i want to pause you
and go back and move
because in blitz you you maybe even just
pre-move hg3
but in a longer game you want to
recognize
that h takes g3 it's not a forcing move
you have another candidate move
you should really consider here yes yes
taking on c6
that's another candidate move what else
bishop takes
mm-hmm which oh i think wow
this is a nice one it's probably bishop
takes right because if the king takes
pawn takes king's run and queen h5 yep
it's winning on the spot
so wow this is i think a very
instructive moment where
the move a lot of players play is just
automatic recapture
but there's cases especially with the
attack on h7
you can just mix up the move order and
it's completely winning
yeah this this line is awesome i guess
the main here we can put it for chat
yeah so it takes
takes king has to move back and
it's yeah it's pretty much worse me i
black could stop it with bishop h4 and
then sack the queen but
uh yeah i figured i'd show this to you
because it's such a common tactical
motif that you you
can see a lot of times in london yeah
i'm like
and i i've played this line for years
and years and i
don't even think of starting with a more
forcing move
but yeah the main time that i get in
these type of positions
where you you see when i change the
moves right yep yeah we're all synced up
i guess mainly when my bishop's on g3
their bishop's always on d6
and instead they're trading with their
bishop which is very annoying because
then once i take here like i don't
really know whether to castle and their
knight on f6 is always defending so
in this position i really like the
trade-off with the bishop but
so i don't like it as much when they're
taking my bishop with their dark squared
bishop
gotcha and that's just another line to
deal with actually when they
play bishop d6 and there's a tension
between the bishops
that's probably one of the most common
lines in the london
where then you you kind of have to know
some theory
and that will uh that will be when like
magnus carlsen's preparation comes in
handy because you'll you'll be prepared
further into the middle game
for those type of positions but sure
i'll let you uh
but yeah if there's like if there is
specific line or game that you want to
jump into
um i guess if you remember the moves we
could just uh
play into the line it should be just
yeah knight f3 here and then bishop
d6 here and instead of c5 let's say they
push like
b6 so
because here we don't do the bishop e5
line anymore which i learned is the best
and i typically go for 95 stuff here
um but i wanted to ask if you have so
the line i normally play is like
we i kind of just play to push e4 maybe
a queen e2
which is the most common idea in these
positions but i was here to be played
anything different
yeah um b6 it's one of these
lines that you have to deal with these
days um
where black will kind of more slow play
like
to understand black's plan black wants
to play bishop b7
uh knight g7 usually queen
[Music]
queen e7 to support the bishop and then
later c5 knight e4
um so there's a few ways to deal with
this one one way is just to kind of do
your own thing and do exactly what you
said
is is go for your usual setup and
sometimes you can still go for 95
and then get like a stonewall setup
where you put your pawn on f4
the bishop can find life on h4 and you
still have a lot of attacking potential
on the king side
is that the line that you normally play
in these positions um
yeah so that that's one of the lines i
probably play most often
um if i know my opponent goes for like
this early b6 bishop b7
and avoids uh like the main line with
early c5 knight c6 um
what i've been looking into recently is
actually not playing bishop g3 but
rather
starting with 95. oh this is what showed
me this oh oh that's so cool
i've been um bishop g3
yeah cause you kind of save a tempo yes
exactly
exactly and this is very cutting edge
theory
yeah if you i'll follow your lead here
because i didn't
this is the one that i think we lost the
move order for
gotcha okay so i i have the file saved
i'll try and remember it this is good
review for me
um so if we just play natural moves for
black
yeah so let's imagine black's natural
setup will be castling
c5 queen c7 knight c6 then
very often like black will go for knight
d7
to challenge e5 so
our setup should be still pretty normal
like
knight knight d2 usually goes to f3 to
support e5
our bishop comes here pawn here and
um very often we still castle so
let's just play out some natural moves
castling
knight d2 c5 c3 queen c7
bishop d3 some of these moves are
interchangeable but you can get to this
position
and yeah yeah i did position with magnus
i i don't think the h4 line
came from one of these positions but
there was some
interesting moves he showed me that
weren't the normal stuff that i play
but i just can't remember what so it's
important with this
line it's very important to like
remember it well
because a small difference in in the
position
like if the knight's not here and and um
the pawn is here
things could it could change the tactics
of of what you're supposed to do in the
middle game
yeah i could show you one trap here um
which is
actually one of the most natural moves
for black is a big mistake
it's a move i kind of showed earlier is
one of the main ideas is to play knight
d7
oh i think he did show me this too oh do
you remember what to do with white
um okay let me i have to think about it
bang bang bang
hmm oh
i'm can we sack here on the same idea
uh so you're you're considering greek
gift um it's good that's one of the
first things that come to mind because
it's the most forcing variation
the problem when you want to go for a
greek if the first question you have to
ask yourself
is after queen h5 in this variation can
black defend h7
and that can just bring the knight back
so if we just play this out for chat
um white's almost winning here but
knight f6
and there's there's no strong attack
yeah okay that makes sense so you have
to be a bit more controlled rather than
just recklessly sack
pieces yeah exactly
tends to do that a lot in my games which
can be fun but
uh yeah it doesn't always work
especially in blitz
thing i feel like i i know there are
some
positions where we can win this pawn but
i
don't think that's
i like the fact you're looking at the
forcing moves like of course the
captures knight takes c6
or takes c5 yeah
there's another candidate move i know
levy says this all
the time like look for checks captures
but what's the third type of move
uh are we talking about still types of
forcing moves
yes chuck's captures and
yeah so the move here is just a simple
attack
no a simple attack
and this this is a target i will say h7
is uh
your focal points knight g5 mm-hmm
okay and the reason why this is so
powerful
is because first of all most of black's
pieces are on the queen side
so mathematically you just have more
attackers
on the king's side than black has
defenders okay
and then if we start looking at the
variations we'll realize that
a lot of the the defensive moves that
look normal just completely fail for
black
um if we look at h6 maybe the most
natural move
uh white's a move how can you continue
to be forcing
and not not retreat but keep moving
forward
queen h5 queen h5 actually looks
playable
um there's something even more forcing
though
like what's the most forcing move in the
position like
oh oh yeah oh wait no i don't think this
oh it does because then we take here and
they don't win our bishop
because we win this yeah yeah you have
to basically see until the end of the
line that d6 is hanging
um and it's just a very nice sequence
you you fork
and you pick up uh like you've won the
exchange
and the pawn and black is just falling
apart
i'm glad we're reviewing this yeah i'll
admit i
i first discovered this line
maybe about a year ago i actually
learned it through watching komski's
streams
okay because he he made the comment that
he's just
playing all his like main preparation
online because there's no over the board
tournaments to play
yeah um you got gotta gotta get it now
while it's out there exactly so i
downloaded all his games and then
scouted out his repertoire and he's
playing this position a lot
awesome uh
night chief oh i guess if they take i
was thinking if they um take our
knight here they have no time because
you're threatening bishop h7 queen h5
oh okay so here just to play it out for
the chat and you know partially sure
so let's say takes here you take check
they
run and instead of taking back we
threaten mate right away
exactly and there's no way now for black
to really
save the king like g6 you take okay
i remember this now yeah it's good to
review like few times
not not only commit it to memory but
really understand
what's going on so if you forget you can
just kind of figure it out like
hopefully you'll
understand the tactical sequences
now if we look at g6 oh okay
like this variation there's a lot of
branches like black can choose from
yeah for sure i mean g6 clearly seems
like a slightly weaker move because of
the dark square well i guess the other
ones were losing
but um let's see what could we do
thing thinking
[Music]
i don't know if we have any tactics
here well our night is still under
attack so we have to do something about
that
be careful not to think too defensively
obviously yeah your your knight is
attacked
but like the first consideration should
be like how can you
how can you tear apart the king's side
because black is a bit misplaced
i thought i was thinking initially like
age 4 age 5
but then i was like well might be a
little bit too slow
yeah we can also always sack your queen
check i looked at that but i don't think
it
led to anything after this i'll tell you
if this was a slower game
you'd wanna you want to spend a lot of
time on this line
queen h5 yes because then you could take
knight here yep turning pawn takes you
have made but instead they could just
take your bishop so here
oh they can't take your bishop because i
mean it looks like it kind of works
it's completely crushing takes okay
takes check like sometimes from a
distance it might be hard to evaluate
but
um i'll say king king regardless of
where the king moves
you're going to sack on g6 exactly
that's not really a sack because if
black takes you you make next move
yeah okay um i think there's like one
tricky line here
if king g7 but uh i mean black is
falling apart like queen h6 you're still
sacking on g6
and then you're getting made here so
yeah uh white's having all the fun
we have mate so there's nothing they can
do
yep okay and then there's one
so we looked at the branches h6 g6
black takes on e5 the best move here
is knight f6 back so black essentially
lost to tempe moving back and forth
and the next move for white it's not
really a
tactical shot but it's just uh it just
adds more pressure to the position
and makes it so black is going to end up
losing something um
for this one i think i'll show you but
um
it's just a matter of trying to remove
the knight on f6
so the way to remember this you're
attacking the pawn two times
rather than adding a third attacker you
just want to remove
one of the key defenders so maybe i'll
i'll have you try and find how can you
attack the knight with uh with a single
piece
knight g4 and uh yeah black is
overwhelmed here because you're
threatening to take with check
and then take and then your queen's
going to come in
and black is very short on defense yeah
they can't do anything and if yeah if
they push then their pawn structure is
just
idiot after we take care like the best
move for black is to play knight e4 and
give
back upon like a center pawn for free um
i guess the fun line to analyze is takes
and then takes
and then black has to take and then
queen h5 and
uh wow it's overwhelming
okay that one's tricky what if um there
was another
i mean wouldn't they so you said this is
the best move but
i mean won't they be winning uh if we go
back one more yeah
yeah would they be winning back our pawn
on f4
here i guess oh yeah so it's it's a
matter of move order
but imagine we take with nice
[Music]
and then i guess it's important that
black if fox plays f5
actually what's the line here we might
have to take on c5
um if they take here we could take the
knight
yeah it gets murky because g2 hangs in
the end yeah
uh
oh oh we just take on g6 first
and then if knight takes on d6 uh we win
h7
and then if queen takes then we take
with bishop
wait but even if they take our and we're
going to hit the queen yeah oh okay okay
that makes sense that makes sense
yeah so these lines got murky but um
i mean this is this is something if you
wanted to
pursue you kind of have a choice between
this move order
um where you keep the bishop on f4 or
other variations where you just move it
back and kind of play your main setup
yeah no i definitely i definitely want
to look at these lines where we don't
play bishop g3 anymore they're very
interesting
yeah yeah i mean they're they're very
interesting they're very venomous and
they're they're
still not so well known even at the high
level
so it takes more work to like fully
understand them
and commit them to memory but it can pay
off if you put in the time to study them
and that is also
for the bishop wait oh i just realized
though the bishop
b5 line though is with bishop g3
so there's different move orders but
yeah so if
if we look at the bishop e5 line because
we actually haven't shown it on board
yet
but um it does involve bishop g3
again there's different movers in london
so you could get it from
from a few different movers but let's
say black plays c5
c3 knight c6 knight d2 this is where you
kind of do the traditional setup
castling i think the main move you
used to play a lot is bishop d3 but
bishop e5 is
the magnus move yeah exactly
it's my move of choice too because i
think there's more traps after bishop e5
compared to the the main bishop d3 line
yes
and then here the main thing why i said
this is so good because
in this position we go for this e4 plan
and typically and it's like black is a
move behind
because normally when they play this
setup they already have their bishop on
b7 you push e4
so that's why that tempo is so important
so magnus did magnus show you like the
whole variation stemming from this
i actually reviewed this in the database
that you gave
okay i included the magnus uh there's a
famous magnus possible
game with the takes on c5 we can
show it right here or no it might move
behind
uh this is all good so just to
understand we play e4
starting with e4 every single move from
white will be some sort of attack or
recapture
so e4 threans e5 recapture recapture hit
the rook
and it's a very flowing variation so
rook b8
um now the rook's aligned with the
bishop so here's where we take
and now we attack the bishop actually
three times
black can't take back on c5 black is
forced to take on g3
and this is actually where i found an
improvement on the magnus carlson game
cause what he played was h takes g3
yeah and i'll just show it what happened
in his game because it was still really
nice
yeah um you took on g3 bosuch played f5
and remember every move you want to be
attacking her
um basically you want to keep initiative
so you don't retreat here
you play the just the simple queen trade
and now what's a winning move is this no
okay you just have to be more confident
but uh this is absolutely crushing
okay but i was curious is does the takes
on h7 line not work after bishop dixie
with the same idea uh so the queens are
could be
traded also your knights on f3
so oh i was thinking you want to take
here
oh i can uh we can look at that i don't
think it does
it's good that you're considering it
though yeah i mean i don't think magnus
carlsen would miss a
tactic like this from his game so i'm
sure it doesn't work but
i'm curious why so if we just play on
the board um there is a nice move here
how can black defend h7 square
oh and i realize they could also
actually they can take on f2 first
yeah yeah that's probably best no it's
okay
but there's queen d3 like worst case
scenario and the queen will defend
yeah yeah but there's probably some
chucks as well
okay that makes sense um so anyway the
improvement that i
found is not to take the bishop first
rather to take the queen first
it could transpose but we give black the
option of maybe taking with check on f2
which is a mistake because after king
takes takes we again have the c6 move
right and then it could transpose if
black just takes back
takes we're threatening the h pawn we're
already up upon because we took and
black never recaptured
so we're guaranteed to i think be up a
pawn here
and again if f5 c6 is a really nice move
okay makes sense um it still takes some
technique like black has an id5 but then
you trade
um and this pawn is gonna you're gonna
hold on to it because after this you
have rook here
you'll trade rooks knight e5 f4 and um
this is how magnus won his game
very nice yeah um
okay so that's good review oh yeah
okay this was my because this bishop b5
line is so nice
but to get into this line that means
that you play bishop g3
which i at first when i was learning
from magnus he said that this is a
better move so
with this 95 you don't even walk into
any of those lines anymore
yeah it's really a choice of what you
want to pursue
um i think you can you can really go
for for either and and sometimes like
what i'll do i'll look up my opponent
beforehand
and see if they would be like
of course this is for serious games or
matches and get a sense of what they're
most likely to walk into
okay um so it's kind of a reference
thing whether you want to play
g3 and get the idea of this one or play
this
with different plans exactly and for you
like i guess when you're playing a lot
of like blitz games or just
training games on stream maybe choose
the one that you're most excited about
learning
but then keep the other one in the back
pocket and that's
one of the nice things about london like
you have different weapons to choose
from you don't have to play the same
thing every time
yeah it's good to mix it up anyway and
get experience in different positions
um is there any other 95 lines um like
what even is the main line for that um
so this specific move order that we
looked at would be the the main
95 line with uh
well without the without the mistake for
black without the 97
oh without 97 yeah so um
if we just review maybe a moment here i
know the moves are saved but
let's say you complete development and
you go into
this i might have to pull up my
my prep i was actually helping a friend
a few weeks ago um exploring a lot of
these variations
so nice yeah i feel like one of these
positions transposed into one of the h4
lines i've been trying to remember but
oh yeah so there's there's a move here
knight e4
oops uh knight f3 of course you have to
defend the knight
and then knight e4 is is a playable move
yes and this is where it can get
complicated and like this is
still still taking me time to fully
understand because it's a big clump of
pieces in the center
yeah big clump yeah and there's so much
tension so
it's easy for both sides to go wrong and
maybe make the
um make a misstep the key here is just
to increase tension
um even further because you have
everything defended
and the move i can recommend is queen c2
okay makes sense they probably would
push f5
yeah f5 is probably like the most
natural move
yep this is what i always get these
setups in my games and
they're just so annoying because they're
so symmetrical and nice
but yeah read everything
and then like play knight e5 push f3 and
that's pretty much all i do
gotcha um so what i can recommend here
and the nice thing about this variation
after f5 is now you can start
simplifying
and get kind of a a nice sort of
positional setup because you're going to
have better control
over the e5 square because this is an
outpost square
when black moves a pawn forward there's
never going to be a pawn coming to f6
or g6 to remove your knights exactly
because i normally try to use the
advantage that
we can attack their knight with her f3
that's something when i try to trade my
knights right
um yeah and you have like looming f3 and
here uh i think you can just simplify
with takes on c6
and if we imagine black just recaptures
you take on d6
let's say recapture and here like you
could
hop into e5 right away there's really no
rush i can castle
finally and you have what we can call a
good bishop
against blacks kind of more depressing
bishop
yeah so this is a lot more positional
compared to what we
saw previously with uh the region
kingside attack
but um it's very pleasant for white and
there's gonna be a lot of cases where
you do end up trading off your bishop
for the knights
and then you'll have a good knight
versus a bishop that can never remove a
knight on e5
defended by your pawn so when is like a
good time for you to trade this bishop
um i guess if black plays c4
then you don't want to move back you
want to take and yeah
otherwise you're not in a huge rush
because the knight's not really
attacking anything
um sometimes it depends on the position
here let's say would you just develop
your rooks
or bring your knight to the center
probably you'd bring your knight i think
95 because they're of course you want to
stay flexible
like um at this point you're not sure if
you want to make the commitment for
trading
but when you play knight e5 let's say
bishop e7 95
you still keep the option open of taking
or playing f3 and then keeping your
bishop
on the board but so in this position
would you
still wait on let's say like after night
then they place them like
i'll just put in a random move oh i
guess well i don't know if you could
actually win a
pawn here i don't know you might be able
to this might be a bad example
so this is a case where even if like for
some reason you could win a pawn by
taking on d7
knight takes g7 it's a move that will
make a lot of
strong players just cringe because
you're trading off your best piece
for box piece that's probably not even
winning
winning a full pawn okay awesome good to
know because some
sometimes i do go for those cheapos take
here and like push b4 and it's kind of a
bad pawn structure but i'm like yeah i
got a pawn but
yeah i think this is a common mistake
even at like
higher level where a lot of players will
be very materialistic like you'll go out
of your way to win material
but you make positional sacrifices and
here it's not worth giving up such a
amazing piece okay so yeah my last
question for this position like i'll
just put in a move for black
would you still wait on taking weight on
pushing
or how would you play these type of
positionals
yeah um again you're not in any rush
what i would be inclined to do here and
there's probably
there's probably multiple paths forward
it's it's one of these positions where
you have a lot of options it's not like
a puzzle where you have one best option
you want to focus on continually
improving like there's still tension in
the center
and your rooks are currently not doing
anything so like getting a rook
to the d-file i feel like would be
useful
in the event i imagine the case where
let's say you have a rook on d1
then when you end up taking there's more
potential to target the
uh the queen and bishop um okay these
are great these are really helpful
because
when i get in these positions i just try
to trade everything right away
because i don't think it really makes a
difference but this this is very helpful
i feel like this is a kind of typical
middle game position where there's no
immediate tactics
you kind of you're left to your own kind
of devices of of what you want to do
how you want to plan and when there's no
open files you usually want
you want to put your rooks on files that
will likely open
or you want to align your rook your
rooks with uh either
the opponent's queen or king because
then there's x-ray vision potential like
more more tackle
tackle potential later so i think rook
d1 would be uh
just nice improving move okay great
perfect um yeah i think that's a like
have questions for
so yeah i mean this line i think you'll
learn the most from actually getting in
games
and just seeing where things branch out
because there's so many branches
and i think we looked at kind of the key
variations the ones that are most likely
to occur
but there's so many i mean there's
options for black too so you kind of
have to learn from uh from actual
gameplay
yeah for sure i mean i'm really glad you
brought this up because i i
totally forgot to start trying knight e5
without bishop g3 so now i can try both
lines in my games
awesome great
so i'm happy to uh i mean i have like
random things prepared
uh if you have games that you want to go
over yeah i had one last
yeah i have two lines that i have
questions
if you have any extra time so my first
question is like bishop a6
lines which i think we could probably
transpose even with a b6
i don't know the best move order for
those but i don't know i don't really
know what to do against the bishop
basics if you're just supposed to trade
i was going to show you i didn't get a
chance to show you earlier but we have a
position on the board
i think it was this one where then we we
transitioned to
just not looking at bishop g3 rather
first play knight e5
um there is a tactical trap that you can
employ
when your opponent plays b6 and you
think they're threatening
like this is pretty common for black to
try and trade off this bad bishop for
your good bishop
so you can prevent this tactically with
pawn c3
yeah i guess position is not exactly a
threat yet but
some players will like stumble into this
just for chat after takes takes queen a4
there you go chat chat is winking nice
so what if they castle first so they
castle then it's it is kind of
difficult to stop um this bishop a6 move
what i would recommend is just to allow
it and whenever they play bishop a6
let's say knight yep bishop a6
then just trade that's what i normally
do
and even though you do trade off one of
your nice london bishops
um black kind of makes a concession
developing the knight
uh a passive square or just kind of out
of play
yeah in this position i don't think this
must be a different possession because
queenie two what would black play
yeah that could have to might have to go
back and reroute or queen c8 i think
they have
maybe like a knight c7 or they normally
don't go back to b8 so
i normally see this line in a slightly
better there might be c5 included
yeah maybe with a c5 so
hold on if we could put c5 first and
then sure
you've already developed your light
squared bishop and then that's when it's
trickier because then we also lose a
tempo taking i think
that's when it annoys me the most yeah
i've i've gone through similar
experiences
uh as a london player um where you
played knight d2
to kind of uh predict that black might
play bishop a6 and then you
don't waste tempo moving your bishop
twice okay um if you wanted to
kind of continue in that sort of
style of not moving your bishop you you
can get away with 95 here
and go for a more stormwall setup um
it's just another kind of idea to to add
to your london jewel box
where um another move you kind of play
the waiting game
yeah if black actually there is a trap
here
curious how how quickly you'll spot this
if knight d7
oh yeah i know this one for sure i
always this is the one trap i know
yeah whenever the bishop's undefended
and there's x-ray vision you can
usually get away with this might have
seven move okay awesome so 95 first that
makes a lot of sense
yep and i think this is this is pretty
straightforward to play in blitz because
your
your setup is still pretty natural black
might get away with bishop a6 with the
trade but you can still
get your pieces to reasonably happy
squares and still have
attacking potential on the king side
okay
yeah so my question was one was the
bishop a6 line and then
the last thing was if they play
um queen b6 super early
before we have c3 push so i let's say
like they push c5 here
and then they go queen wait and it's it
wasn't the night where you play knight
a3
uh okay i love my game this is a game
that you played
on may 1st okay
you got absolutely destroyed so i'm
sorry to bring up painful memories
no it's okay sometimes i i might just be
like careless and i know the better
move but maybe it's something that i
have no idea how to play against
the thing is i came across a scheme and
i didn't really
know what you did wrong and i actually
like in my process
of trying to dissect what your mistake
was
i actually learned something really
useful too which is a line i
had not explored before so
it's nice to learn from other people's
mistakes that way i don't suffer the
pain but i still
yeah come away with the wisdom
i tried knight a3 right so you played
93.
i don't know what to do when they start
attacking my my d4 pawn that's another
issue
uh okay so in this game
first of all i was proud that you played
knight a3 because i know we covered this
idea
last time so if they take you play this
and
like this is already considered to be uh
to be fun for white at the very least of
a draw um with a perpetual but there's
lots of ways black can go wrong
yeah thank you for this line i was i'm
always so excited when i get the night
a3 because it's unusual
and it throws off and it's the one move
i remember
so right yeah and on top of that you
have knight c4
um i know again mata like had
recommended some e6 but he didn't
actually cover knight a3
but if black plays a6 you play this and
you're happy
in this game your opponent played
probably one of the battery moves
d6 and you played knight c4 this is good
queen c7 and then you played a4
and your opponent played bishop e6
and this is where things just started
falling apart for you
because i was starting to take here and
this
yeah it was awkward and this was
actually not a position i had studied
before but it's like very natural for
black to
just go into this and just to show what
happened in the game
just to give some context you played b3
um
but b3 weakened your diagonal and then
at some point your queen side just
collapsed like his pawn is super weak
yep exactly i remember this so the
mistake
that you made was actually kind of
subtle there may have been
some improvements after b3 but the
moment i want to focus on is actually
this position
where you played a4 i assume you you
were wanting to prevent b5
because it looks normal for black to
play b5 here and kick away your knight
b5 is a move that you actually you would
be very happy if black
plays because then even though it you
lose time moving your knight again
probably you have to go back to d2
then you have a target to attack even if
they just defend with like a6 don't they
just have more space so i'll give you an
example line
yeah the key is to just allow b5 and
play a more useful developing move
uh knight f3 and i think that the key
moves so
look at here to understand the position
are b5 and bishop e6
um if b5
you calmly move back to d2
hitting the b pawn and then
after a6 you uh you actually have a few
options a4 is the most thematic
where okay you just and this is actually
very typical in london
whenever black has an early a6b5
um a4 is just a very thematic pawn break
okay
and there's no like you're already
attacking the pawn it's a bit
overextending for black to play b4
um and you're gonna be more developed
and um
it's just a bit more pleasant to play
you just where do you
want to develop your bishop do you use
the c4 square at all
actually yeah i would be inclined to
move to c4 just because d5
can't be played anytime soon
um but bishop d3 yeah either one of
these squares i think is
is reasonable right here and keep in
mind like black
used a lot of time just moving queen
side pawns
yeah after bishop d3 you have all your
minor pieces developed
yep exactly they only have moved their
queen and all their pawns and
we're ready to castle yep another uh
another option just to point out this is
an engine's recommendation
which is actually kind of cool is to
take on c5
now the move you usually want to play
but
the purpose is to then strike with c4
then the queen's a target because rook
c1 is coming and
black's a bit underdeveloped is this the
com
is this a better computer line i believe
so
um c4 or even e4 it's giving but
c4 looks uh it's easier to understand
yeah the a4 seems more comfortable to
play because it's
more principled but yeah the computer
line doesn't make sense
yep so
and another thing to address the reason
why you play knight f3
is if bishop e6 then you'd be in a
similar situation to your game
the only difference is you have your
knight here and not your pawn on a4
okay so this knight can play a very nice
role
in diverting the tension away from
the fact that your knight is target and
you have a really nice move that uh
doesn't usually exist in so many london
lines
is knight g5 okay
yeah and then this was an idea that i
tried to use in my game but
here i must can't they do the same
threat where they
oh we would have a bishop check so
you're going to be striking first
well f7 would hang in that line like
takes takes for
immediately threatening the pawn okay
nice
so um yeah this was a few days ago i was
uh i was just having fun with
some analysis um
i actually totally forgot how i
misplayed this because yeah it's not
something so obvious that i remember i
wanted to show you just one funny line
i came across an analysis because i
thought it's natural for black just to
move here
and then look to kick away the knight
and then there's a really cool engine
move pawn e4
uh sac upon sacrifice after which if
black
takes you take
bishop takes and then queen e2 skewering
the bishop and then if the bishop moves
there's um take one there's a pin but
there's also a fork
i call this a pork and you're you're
forking pinning and winning
a lot of very nice yeah actually if here
and then you you take and
fork and this is a discovered fork so
so when he forks yeah anyway um
it's just a funny line like it goes to
show
yeah like when you're ahead in
development you'll have more fun tactics
in your opponent
okay no this line is awesome i'll
definitely remember this okay
so knight f3 first
um so did you did you want to bring in
the game
like the other queen b6 game yeah i
think
it's just d45 bishop f4 and c6
and then and then they will play queen
v6
ah that was what ada so there there's a
uh this sort of i wanted to say infamous
it's kind of a famous game
with hecaro playing it was an over the
board tournament
in vegas picard was black and he beat a
grand master in 11 moves
and he was playing uh i mean 2600 rated
grand master
uh wow and beret playing white played b3
here
uh which is already a slight inaccuracy
we'll get back to this
um hikaru develops
it might help if you look from blackside
okay
uh because black will be the the winner
in this game so e3
and then hicaro like keeps playing
aggressively knight h5
bishop g5 okay kicks the bishop
plays knight g7 and this is a round
where berea like goes terribly wrong
um and plays knight e5 which actually
looks natural at first
hitting the knight typical london move
the problem is after takes
um white can't take back on e5
and this is just a quick tactic for you
black to move and win a piece
yeah we got a nice little fork yes uh
using the
triangles of the board so
bereave takes the knight on g5
and then knight g4
and the queen is regretting its life
decisions
bishop g3 was played because g6 was a
threat to drop the queen
um g6 was still played queen h4
hecaro played one more move and bereave
resigned
okay and it's such a normal move too
it's probably the move most people would
play
bishop g7 because we also have this
threat yeah
just developing but with the threat of
trapping the queen
no and brave just resigned here he could
have played
on like the move to play on is bishop e5
but it's so so good for black because
you take and at the gm level is just
losing for white
that's funny that there is it's only
losing a pawn though
it is but after it takes takes
oh yeah there's
development yeah two bishops and
okay yeah i see why the gm would resign
here that makes sense
so i think this is one of the quickest
grand master losses
ever with white playing the white losing
with the london
it's hard to lose quickly yeah
london supporters it's not a good look
anyway so the way so i remember seeing
this game
and um i wasn't like a very active
london player at the time but then a few
years later
i decided to investigate this line and
if we flip back to white's perspective
what i can recommend after queen b6
is not to be materialistic
black is trying to win the pawn
but neglecting developing the minor
pieces
just give them the pawn keep developing
play in knight d2
oh okay if black takes the pawn you can
play e4
and i can say there's full compensation
for white here you probably don't need
to study this too extensively if you
remember
e4 it's going to be more fun for white
to play
okay this is also the computer's top
choice like engine will give i think
plus
0.5 for white good to know so it's a
pretty rare line but it's one of these
things that it's good to kind of have in
your back pocket
in case you run into it if they play
like
knight f6 do we push um
that's a good question if knight f6 i
think you can just keep the tension like
keep developing
yeah i guess play safe just castle
actually the rule is
when you have like the lean development
especially like this
you'd rather open the position rather
than close the position
e5 kind of closes things down oh that's
that's a great tip
so because we're down a pawn but we're
ahead in development we want to keep the
pressure instead of closing if things
open up there will be more tactical
opportunities because white has so much
development
makes sense and you can probably push
later if flack trades on e4
uh then your pieces come into play and
i do see the engine here is giving um
giving a pleasant edge to white um
so yeah i don't think this is anything
to worry about good good
no i didn't i've never seen i've like
definitely played 92 before but i never
considered e4 so
another new idea for me to remember it's
not a move that you get to play too
often because usually like you commit to
e3
but i guess that's why like you you
start with knight f3
um in case black does go for this line
yeah and if black plays knight f6 and
you're in time to
play rook b1 if you want there's other
ways to gamut if you want to play c4
but um it's a matter of preference
yeah if they if they don't take the pawn
um here would you
you would play c4 here or it would
depend on the situation
i think if this were like a a slower
game i'd be more inclined to play
knight b3 or rook b1 okay just to play
more position
if this were blitz chess i'd probably
play c4 pretty quickly
okay and then what this could what could
end up happening
is if bishop f5 you play queen b3
oh yeah you could transpose into the
setup i think we looked at briefly last
time yeah
yeah yeah this yeah will you play
against the copycat the copycat
variation
exactly i c4 and
if they take oh well if
if they take on v2 after c4 is that a
threat at all
so this one is a bit more murky that's
why like i said in blitz i would
more be more inclined to play c4 because
this one
um like you can't get an e4 i remember
stockfish saying this is okay for white
yeah some like rook b1 uh you sack
another pawn but you have the files and
then you play e3 and
even though you're down to pawn
stockfish is saying it's close to equal
so yeah i mean i can understand why you
play this in blitz because
your moves to develop you can play
really quick and i mean they're they're
queen so far
they're likely to fall on some tactics
yeah yeah so again it's matter if you
want to be like crazy and get out of its
stuff or if you want to be more
controlled but
it is nice having an option try both in
my blitz games
nice yeah i think for you you just want
to like keep getting experience and keep
kind of reviewing your lines like making
sure
that you're continually expanding your
repertoire
exactly i think we covered like a lot of
a lot of good stuff that uh it's kind of
the next layer
um compared to just remembering the
basic setups
yeah i know great because i definitely
think one thing that will help
me break like my rating plateaus is
playing
positions that i'm not used to and these
are definitely old
stuff i've never played before this is
great yeah
i think like especially if you want to
improve when you switch
switch up things even a little bit you
might even
drop reading because you're playing
things you're not
you haven't played before but yeah long
term it will teach you more about the
game it'll improve your understanding of
chess and
that's how you can overcome plateaus
exactly
um i did have one more question this
one's kind of random i'm just curious
if against the england gambit
you go for a bishop f4 line or you play
something else i always play bishop f4
because i like it if they walk into
something like this but i was curious
what if you played something different
yeah um i i usually just play the
main line like if if they go for the
trappy
first of all there's a few traps they
can go for i assume you're referring to
this one
yeah which this one i actually like is
white because you play bishop d2
takes here and then as long as you don't
fall into like bishop c3
and this really sad rage you get me i've
learned my lesson
i don't play this anymore so knight c3
is a key move
uh i know amman hamilton likes to play
the queen sack
well yeah where he like stacks his queen
yeah i hate
you should you should look forward to
this as white because white's exactly
objectively better but it's still like
tricky to win
yeah i always i guess most of the time
i'm winning and then i kind of just
blunder later
but you definitely have a big advantage
from the beginning if you want something
a bit
offbeat and tricky i'll admit i
i haven't studied it too thoroughly but
there is
a very interesting video on youtube it
was by jonathan trance on his youtube
channel
where he shows a really offbeat line and
try and find the link
but he shows knight's e3 trance
shrance yes uh s-c-h-r-a-n-t-z
ah okay got him got him could probably
google his name in uh
england and finally find the video
oh yeah it's called a completely
pointless refutation to this
the uh england gambit okay
got it but the the
quick summary he just he shows a line
where you
you allow block to take the bishop on f4
oh yeah which looks like you just
blundered a bishop
but computer still gives plus 1.36
because you have knight d5 or maybe
around plus one
and um this line is funny and not too
many england gamut players will be
prepared for this is this what you play
sometimes or
this is what i've wanted to learn
because like seeing the video i just
didn't
i haven't studied it so thoroughly and
you kind of have to know
a little bit further after queen e4 and
things get a little bit chaotic but it
is objectively still fine for whites
okay gotcha and then just so
i want to make sure you know the other
trap in the england
if black plays bishop c5 how would you
play as white
just play as you would normally
and then i normally play like bishop
f4 but
um i actually had a game like this
this morning oh i think i took the pawn
here but i don't think that's
right well yeah this was an hour
oh oh i have fallen for this i find for
this many times where you take and then
they take care i phoned for this on
stream
but oh really yeah this is uh this has
been making its rounds yeah this one
i've fallen from million times on the
stream but when you
when you prepare me say oh this is a
trick i won't fall for the
the queen drop it's incredible like this
was
uh this has been like
making its rounds and like uh on all the
platforms
i get so mad when i fall for this and
i've fallen for it on stream so many
times
yeah and like there's different
variations if it takes here then knight
e7
and then a lot of people will stumble
into it
yeah like accidentally pre-moved or
something
and then like not jokes on you well it's
as black
yeah black uh after d6 you want to
pre-move knight e7
so after takes 97's fight instantly and
white doesn't think twice
yeah i can see why england people play a
lot in bullet
yeah i've uh one of my most viewed
videos on youtube is like trapping a
bunch of people in this uh
this exact line you play the england
gambit
uh i went through a phase of playing it
i've been playing it a bit less recently
but it's still fun to play every once in
a while
gotcha gotcha even there's there's been
gm's walking into this trap so it's a
funny one
yeah i like the england game i don't
think it's necessarily good but i just
get so annoyed when people played
against me it's tricky you just have to
kind of know how to
not fall into the trap and win a pawn
and
get a better position so so you do
so bishop f4 is okay uh even taking the
pawn i can recommend taking the pawn
um oh if you want to be really dirty
actually because a lot of people
pre-move knight e7
yeah you can take on d6 i don't
recommend this
but if they pre-moved 97 they look
ridiculous because then you take here
and you just want a bishop when you
would have to risk
giving your queen yes so
if if they don't pre-move then you're
the one looking ridiculous
yeah i don't know if i would take this
risk but maybe in like 30-second chess
i'll tell you the the line i can
seriously recommend
take the pawn don't take the knight but
play knight c3
then you defend your queen some people
won't realize the queen's defender
they'll play this
then you take the knight and they don't
have the tactic they might even lose
their bishop too
okay nice then even if they take back
the pawn if they take back you have
knight b5 or
knight actually
yeah you probably want to play this or
this eventually
i mean also e4 a lot of ways to
just get a fun pleasant position okay um
actually i kind of like this move
before and to try to first and develop
the night before
nice okay god mental note
yeah it's good approach like uh
especially if you want to
get better at chess and optimize your
winning chances just learn how to refute
like the dubious gambits
yeah you lose so many games to these but
yeah i
started coming up my bishop at four line
works better but i knew it wasn't
correct so
good to know okay those are all my
questions
awesome yeah i think we covered a lot i
don't want to overwhelm you with like
too much stuff
and you're definitely not around but
yeah we can
we can just make it an hour if that
works with you too but if you had any
other positions you want to bring up i'm
happy to
continue looking but you are the one
i'll i'll give you
just two more like offbeat london lines
that i wanted to show you
the last time i don't think we got to
and they're just kind of
mini like mini appetizer or maybe
dessert
in this case and it's a reason
one reason for the move order like
starting with bishop
f4 let's imagine black goes for the very
quick
bishop d6 there's a nice little sideline
that you can play here
play that queen g4 stuff yeah you can
play queen g4 right away or you can take
i sp in your database and i was very
suspicious
ah i'm trying to remember maybe i did
show you this at some point
last time
but i just looked at all your databases
gotcha
i i really like playing this in blitz
because no one's prepared for it
okay so yeah i was gonna ask about is
this like a bullet line
like would this is i think objectively
the best line for white i discovered
this by just using the engine
okay it's an idea you see more often in
the french
where you attack the undefended pawn and
whatever black does to
defend it there's some concession like
king f8 loses casting rights g6 weakens
the dark squares
queen of f8 undevelops a queen there's a
trap if queen before
check you defend and if they take the
pawn they're losing
because then too many things are
attacked in black's uh box camp
okay um so
it's a nice line and if like more people
or most people play g6 you you develop
normally
queen goes here you castle and it's uh
a different setup but still very very
playable
okay great and then one more kind of
similar to this sort of style
i think that was that one somewhere in
your database but i don't remember this
one
i may have included the other one too i
saw you had a recent game
uh against a queen's indian setup
yes which i need to start remembering oh
queen's indian never mind we're not
playing
yeah so queen's indian refers to exactly
the salah from black
then here you can play it's a move
that's
um i think it's it's lila lila's top
choice
is queen f3
oh yeah it's very strange to do this in
the london like
rather than knight f3 but you you force
black to do something awkward to defend
the rook
knight c6 either knight c6 or d5 and
regardless of what move is played
you can say d5 you play knight c3 you
castle
you have g4 you have the pawn swarm
ideas you have queen g3
so it's a different setup but um it
throws a lot of people off and
it's nice to um mine's nice to
experiment
with this in blitz so pretty much yeah
these two lines is because we have a
tempo with the queen and then the king
side castle attack on on the king side
because you have that extra turn
where you got to take your queen out so
you yeah basically developing your queen
with tempo
normally i wouldn't show this to like a
beginner player because you don't want
to move your queen out too early
but these are exceptions to the rule
where you move out with tempo and you
accelerate your development okay these
are great these are great
and the bonus if you play a lot of
bullets a lot of players pre-move bishop
e7
yeah these this one your notes i do
remember this one yeah and then after
takes and then here
there's a bonus trap like takes here and
then here and
cutting edge theory so awesome these are
great
anyway hopefully this gives you even
more inspiration to
keep playing london i guess excited if
someone plays into either of these two
yeah yeah definitely i'd say like
make an effort to get in like training
games
um and play your lines keep reviewing
them and
if you have games that you're not sure
what you did wrong or you want
recommendations against certain things
just uh make a note and i'm happy to
answer any questions in the future
yeah it's awesome i mean i brought all
the positions that i had issues and you
literally solved them all secured all my
issues so that's awesome
oh yeah it's a pleasure
i love these london lessons they're the
best chess lessons ever
i enjoy them too yeah hopefully it
brought some value for for chat
and maybe some people complaining that
they hate the london they don't know how
to play against it so
maybe someday we'll have to do an
anti-london lesson